[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody happy Friday I'm John
Luke I'm joined by and it's me again
we're back we're back it's been a couple
weeks since we've done this been because
things keep happening but we're not
gonna let them to tear us cuz we're
playing Halo 2 this week been exactly
this is the one maybe like right up
there with Halo 3 that I've been really
waiting for them hmm it seems like there
might be some some kind of intimate
submit some issues maybe a little bit
issues yeah yeah but we'll we'll run it
out and we'll have a good time we'll
just mess with this see what's up with
you guys community Friday's exactly
we're going to wear so we I'm sorry I'm
so scramble this morning the trying to
fix fix all that weird tech issues I was
having so for one we have a new look if
you've you can now see we have a nice
clean new fancy colors which I actually
am quite into it's the normal process as
usual if you've played with us before
with Halo specifically we like the
easiest way is that if you join the
GameSpot steam group which the link
there is a URL in the description we
also have right here on the video itself
below us is the URL if you join that and
then you join the steam group and then
you go to the chat here you should be
able to click on my name and join us and
that is the easiest way to join and play
with us yeah also speaking of the the
new color in the background in the sub
looks very good okay I can't help but
notice that it looks like it's the same
color as Devore's brain and the Mortal
Kombat potato mode we did yeah I mean I
I went to the are you I department and I
said I need you to change everything and
make it look like pretty I needs over
bring I need he's got your flavors
what if game spot but gushers but that's
the perfect if you haven't watched it
you definitely should I yell a lot I
yell more than I usually do
it's a really good video I'm pretty
after that one yeah yeah alright we're
gonna jump in we're gonna warm up while
people people hop in and join you uh I
believe so no people should be able to
join the party hopefully if you're
having issues please let me know
oh my god I'm are getting shot at yeah
big shame I made the mistake of being
one of the first people to step out I
think the weird the weird thing that's
always been with playing these Halo
games on PC is is like adjusting to
actually playing on the mouse and
keyboard
yeah I'm definitely going to be
switching between the two and controller
and mouse and keyboard to live chat if I
can see more people okay yeah so you got
we got Brandon's in the chat hanging out
heck yeah it was good sigh Brandon got
all the usual suspects
need to figure this out it's been kind
of a weird release uh you were saying
how like it's been buggy it's kind of
been a bad one which is some wild stuff
with shooting walls some wild stuff just
projectiles not working right but I
think the one I'm really excited for is
gonna be Halo 3 on pc i love halo 2 like
i love it's multiplayer but i've also
like that freshness III played halo
vista halo 2 this yeah it's like I I'm
sort of like oh yeah yeah this is what
it was like to play on PC back and uh I
think it's like watch 2006 so it's more
like I'm like oh yeah I remember this
and a bit like everything's just
populated yeah
it's but now it's like I'm waiting for
Halo 3 cuz that's the one that's like
bring that to PC man let's go I kinda
wanna keep trying that shoot the ground
thing what's the main part of your
channel so the main thing we do is we
were GameSpot we cover we cover video
games you see like reviews or hmm stuff
from events that happens we also do live
streams almost every day almost now yeah
we don't do them as as regularly as we
do but we still do this or we're messing
around with that a bit yeah mostly
previews reviews cool features and it's
kind of talking about games that we all
like there we go Master Chief collection
already had two so this is on the PC
though PC we're playing on PC
they're slowly adding it each game over
time they've been actually really good
about releasing them to the point where
I feel pretty confident they'll probably
have they'll get everything up here by
the time by the end of the year for
infinite I'm still holding out hope that
they
they like I know like that file size
would just be stupid but like I wish
they would add five to this just because
I like the idea of Master Chief
collection being like this this like UI
wrapper that all Halo games and exist in
you know they're trying to do like at
like a Halo Waypoint thing for that but
it wasn't like the actual games linked
together
I remember Halo Waypoint that was kind
of weird it was basically just like a
weird website browser thing yeah I was
doing that Xbox like the all-in-one
everything's connected and it's like
actually no one cares about that but I
like the idea of Halo of mask you've
collection being this like hub for older
Halo games like I'm you know obviously
I'm not expecting like infinite or
whatever like I don't want them to feel
like I don't want new Halo games to feel
held back by the architecture the Master
Chief collection however I think it'd be
cool if older Halo games Scott retro
actively added to it tango I'm also
playing like garbage so Master Chief
collection isn't on PC so it's on PC but
it's not complete yet yeah yeah so
basically you can buy it okay so if you
have an Xbox and you have game pass you
you have the game on PC as well which is
cool you can just do just play it on the
Windows 10 store otherwise you can buy
it on Steam it is I think it's 40 bucks
and you get everything and then as they
add new Halo games they will be added to
the collection otherwise you can buy
them individually I just had the didn't
flip and shoot the wall thing happen
like to you or did you do it
no I did it to someone Wow
it said I betrayed my teammate because
the rocket exploded on them when they
were so how does this work you just
shoot the wall so you just yeah you're
sending like walls
and the they like shot needs to register
somewhere or something so it just picks
whatever person is around you and weird
all right I think I just hear how with
that now took years war over halo I like
yours a lot but there's there's
something that I just really really
liked about halo yeah you planning
geared tactics I installed it but I
haven't had the chance to play it I need
to play more but I like that so far I
mean I like it too I like the idea of it
it's it's so it fits so well like it's
just everything about it makes like like
the mechanics of gears translates to
like a XCOM style tactical game I'm just
like I'm shocked how well this works I
also like I'm so my JRPG whole I haven't
gotten out of there oh yeah I feel like
every week I'm adding a new game tonight
my pile of games to play and it's
unhealthy yeah you know I have an xbox
one building a PC and almost done but
we're picking up a PC now heck yeah I
mean you'll be able to hang out and join
us when you do it because I'm sure we'll
be playing a low I could Evi Friday's
not just today but a whole bunch of days
cuz we both really like it you do you
like it and it's an easy one to play
everyone loves it some fun lag oh you
got something you got that fun lag the
fun like that the other person had when
they tried to run away oh yeah I'm
seeing that some of that fun lag yeah
yeah right back back back back back a
better great time
I thank you Daniel I hope that you also
have a great time it's it's Friday I'm
excited almost almost the weekend yeah I
shouldn't have kept trying to go with
that I as much as I love halo I can't
hang with the sniper rifles well not not
good enough
that's a shotgun oh damn it
more of a battle rifle dual wield kind
of guy but you know week a long week it
has has been a long week for everyone
okay
those not a great warm-up but there's no
I really wasn't let's hop out here and
see if anyone joining why was the no
stream last week so I had construction
happening outside my window the neighbor
thought it'd be the perfect time to call
a bunch of people out to redo his entire
driveway so oh so I gotta sit there
basically mute myself a whole bunch and
that's no fun you guys would hear a
bunch like jackhammering and stuff and
just kind of figured with all the other
stuff we had going on that I would
probably be alright so to kind of skip
it but we're back and his driveway I
think is done they're out there looking
at it now oh heck am I out here he
sounds though so let's keep holding hold
that hope that the RF and then the week
before that we were going to stream and
then an hour before the stream started
uh my apartment yeah well because uh
there is an electrical fire outside of
my apartment in our building so we had
to leave
thankfully it was it was quickly caught
and contained and and the building's
fine enough no no damage or anything but
that is why unfortunately I had to like
cancel that stream 2 weeks ago that
feels like a lifetime ago it does
everything feels like it's so long yeah
this I can't wait I can't wait for all
this stuff to be over Ben those
technical issues I was having 30 minutes
ago feels like two weeks ago yeah right
not so far in the the review not even
thinking about it it's wild we got b-17
Eagle
joining us excited getting that getting
that party together if any of you else
want to join please hit us up I joined
the GameSpot steam community group you
can also if you do have it on Windows 10
you would have to you can also join us
but you would need to be Xbox but I am
more than welcome to add you as like a
follower if we want to make that work so
hit me up and let me know playstation
here prefer Gears of War over that's Hey
Gears of War is a very good game wait
why are those guys all standing still
what's happening what is happening I got
a triple kill keep it going don't stop
don't question it midships who do it
good ass matters bishop is really nice
there was a point in time where like
we're playing Halo in the office like
late at night and I felt really good
because at one point like was it it was
Nick Marguerite I've heard of this
infamous story I believe yeah we we
ended up doing a thing where everyone's
like alright we're tired of you doing
your thing and they did like a 3v1
against me and I end up completely
sweeping it in midship and I felt really
good but halos good details real good
yeah well that's not what I want
I also really missed the feeling of like
running up on someone and then just male
8 a.m. yeah it's a it's a good time Oh
No
oh so that from the sword oh why would I
eat damn it
hold on go a shotgun beats sword every
time if you could tell me right yeah I'm
about it
let me start playing judgment heck yes
Brandon awesome judgment spent to ask a
talk more people play yeah cuz of things
I am sorry that I betrayed you I
shouldn't be it's a good that's like a
double like bad thing to do because not
only do I kill you but I stole your
killed that you've worked really hard
for hmm I'm the worst
did you finish judgment I did you did
finish judgment yes okay it's a it's a
really good game and I really like the
subject manner that they chose because
of something that you don't ever touch
on in games yes and I really did it
really well and I think that game's cast
of characters is a fantastic Oh got it
with the stuck well I really hope Kato
shows up in more stuff yeah like they
need to show up in like yeah keys to 7/8
they need or like make a judgement to
them good boys
you know that uh the ending credits
where it's just Yaga mean Kaito hanging
out in their apartment and their their
detective agency and then there's like
they're chasing a cat and you're like oh
this is excellent this is it this is
what I wanted
well that sort guys gonna jump down yeah
you guys should know that you guys are
my favorite game spot stuff ever boar
toast ad oh my god i I'm flattered and I
appreciate it that's the highest honor I
can ever receive it's true oh shoot yeah
look up flickered a bed oh no okay
today's may be thank renewed may have oh
I feel bad I had committed and it was I
had to write it out man there's nothing
you could do oh I was trying to go for
the shotgun Eagle doing it doing it
doing good here keeping it going know my
body this Matt just been a very lot of
close quarters yeah all the Covenant
carbine I do the carbines sound good I'm
gonna touch this in so long
I love the Covenant carbine how do you
know it's it's the flippin wall thing I
think it's mostly with explosions cuz
there was there was no one there that's
what happened that last with the grenade
or this was our warm-up match no unknown
soft but I I like got killed twice by my
ally from like a rocket blast that I
didn't see coming
and I was like I'm convinced that was
part of that that would glitch the guy
was all the way across the map I'm back
baby damn one for Ben good job 24 and
what though that's the question I got to
make sure they that Katie's on point
twenty four and seven is twenty four and
seven isn't a fight yet to what I got a
12 and seven I'll take that that's okay
yeah as long as you're positive really
happy when all right let's hop out for a
sec see if there's anyone else that
wants to join in do we got any way to
blow hell yeah it is
let's see here
by the way if you ever want to keep more
up to date with the games we're playing
and make it easier for you to join and
play with us you should go ahead and
join d GameSpot official discord server
that we now have up or we know so we're
still we're still we're still bringing
it we're still do an invite on an invite
basis so if you want in at me or at then
and will hug me good [ __ ] we'll hook you
up we'll get you in there and then that
way you can see what games were playing
and being able to join us ahead of time
as well as just engaging with a very
very lovely community of people that's
been really let's just keep going
okay anyone else oh like I'm gonna keep
using my controller after that game yeah
oh we're using the controller oh you
betcha it just it feels right and I was
rocking that that shotgun and this so
weird the whole time ego gets a he just
mentioned real cool people in the
discord that's right it's true see
mister I used to play quake 2 and ps1
with three friends and local multiplayer
we should just where's my quick let's
play quake or Unreal Tournament at some
point that's how we got started with
comity Fridays as I play quake champions
because I like back in and it was the
only excuse to play it because no one
plays that game I haven't touched that
game in a hot minute I'm imagining it's
I know it's still up but I can't imagine
it's in a good state right now I mean a
group of friends installed and returned
in 2004 like a week ago and we played
that those servers are still up it's
still going it still plays really well
so I'm telling ya that's the 1i that
yeah that game is great what what other
I'm trying to go like really old games
that you just like are always shocked
that are still up you check those
servers and you had people still in here
we should play some
oh shoot that scared me should play some
counter strike 1.6 like Warcraft 3 mod
yeah if we do that we're getting Michael
in here for that you don't want me
playing kind of like 1.6 I'm terrible at
it
I mean I'll play it but you don't want
me uh you don't want to look at my
screen you wanna look at Michael's
screen Oh
ditched my SMG like a fool ain't got
flanked mr. Huxter lock was a really
good time to like not the not the second
one so much but I love the first one I
wasn't good at it but I loves playing
get him get him get him get him get him
get him get him get him there we go oh
shoot
ah naylet Magnum SMG is the best dual
wield option I know mathematically
that's not true but like I love it so
much
what is this game it looks old this halo
too
let's be that halo 2 man mm [ __ ] and if
if you haven't played it it's it's
probably one of my favorite shooters
yeah personally it's still nothing quite
like it
yeah in my opinion but uh this this
version of it on PC just came out this
week mm-hmm dad dropped on Tuesday nice
whoever swooped in and saved the day
I'll take the assist that's fine with
you okay
it's on Steam Windows Store and Xbox
just like zst and if you got game pass
you have it as well what but it's like a
collection of all the Halo games yeah
but you can also buy them individually
for like 10 bucks apiece
the one thing that's there eventually
adding that's pretty cool that a lot of
people don't know about sir they're
planning on adding cross play with Xbox
yeah they like they'll I put it in the
middle of like out like a like a update
a blog post and I remember seeing that
me like whoa what
all right in cross play like not making
it like a big headline yeah it was weird
it was like okay like I really
appreciate their commitment to keeping
this game updated and alive because I
mean you know this game has had a
tumultuous history which actually did a
video about a couple years ago called
fixing the Master Chief collection so if
ever curious about like if you're not
familiar with how busted this game was
when it came out you should check that
out because I kind of dive into that
yeah I got a shot Commission roll up on
him and I definitely did that's on me
for not paying attention
Crosswhite between Xbox and PC across
flight between Steve and Windows Store
so it is already cross play between
Steam and Windows Store that's available
right now if you have it on the Windows
Store through game pass or bought it you
also can play with people on Steam
because steam just uses Xbox Live for
like to play the game they're eventually
going to add cross play between Xbox and
Windows Store and Xbox and Steam so
eventually all three of those platforms
will be able to simultaneously just play
with each other which will be excellent
and then theoretically infinite Halo
match infinite halo matches everyone can
use Halo infinite matches where
everyone's here
oh I can't wait for Master Chief we kept
putting uh smash brothers no okay i
revengeance you because you saved me the
lack of rule the lack of cross play for
the next generation will seem so
prehistoric I mean my hope is that cross
play will become a standard next
generation I feel like that's the
direction it's going right like more
more games more big games or adding
cross play themselves Microsoft has been
pushing it I think new hardware and new
architecture is the perfect time to
integrate cross play more directly into
you like the way those consoles work so
I'm really hoping that that Microsoft
and PlayStation are making a huge push
to to integrate cross play into those
systems because I think that is is a is
the direction everything's going in I'd
kill for a new timesplitters or like
dinosaurs HD didn't they do time way
Oh didn't they do a times what is HDMI
crazy oh no they they put like three of
the levels in the latest home front game
oh and then left it at that
heck yeah so killing it best team all
right
interesting to us PC players have an
advantage but they're insane council
pros - so that's the thing like I'm
playing with the controller right now
even though we're on PC yeah it depends
on the game of course but I think in a
lot of cases if you're good you're just
gonna be good yeah I it's weird because
I I know in my head like a PC first
person came there got a warden Mouse but
like I'm busted and broken like I'll
play destiny with a controller too cuz
I'm used to all right anyone else nope
no one yet that's okay but member guys
if you want to play with us and you're
able to please go ahead and join sure
the aim assist is definitely a thing Oh
on this thank you yeah for for me it
comes down to not like the aim assist is
definitely a big helper but it's just
like I know where the buttons are and I
know what they do and I know the exact
timing for like I switched my weapon I
reloaded now I can pick up my like to
wield weapon all in this timeframe yeah
in all one smooth movement because I
know exactly how to move my hand to do
it absolutely I mean I yeah I think
there are some games that just it just
feels better like I actually do better
on apex with a controller you feel what
I'm playing on PC yeah well thanks for
dropping by to say have a good day Leila
is good too good to see ya
hope you have a good day too and you
also stay safe
mmm halo is meant for control a sister
really it really was it feels like it
feels like an engagement for controls
yeah it feel there are parts of it that
feel good with keyboard and mouse but
overall it just it feels better on a
controller yeah Alex I'm really good
still haven't finished still haven't
finished it I am I'm really close I'm
like a level or two from the end I it it
the problem is is that I get to a point
where I go like I should play it and
then I'm like thinking about setting up
the VR and I go
okay I guess I got to set up the VR and
then I don't do it I feel bad that's
that's nothing gets to call it that game
that's purely my laziness but I really
need to finish it let's just say like I
get that you know my VR headset so
pretty next to me I can just grab it
yeah both like just micro hi I'm Anne
Jake Decker are like you finishing it I
got to talk to you about that ending I'm
like god I really need to do that I'd be
I feel terrible
yeah I should too
I don't run away from me after I pop
your shields like you're supposed to
goddamn make it well is this a remaster
so we're playing we're basically playing
through all the Halo 2 maps the massive
question comes with base halo 2 in
anniversary so on the multiplayer front
they imported the entirety of halo 2's
multiplayer and then they did an
anniversary version the multiplayer
which is where I think they took like
six maps and redid them as well as add
forged support so that's what we're
playing right now is we're playing the
anniversary version and it's kind of
this middle it's like this weird version
of Halo 2 that has like aspects of Halo
2 speed but then also aspects of like
Halo 4 and 5 it's kind of weird
yeah it has a real good halo like 5 look
to it but it still kind of feels like
halo 2 yeah I kind of dig it I kind of
like it as the Sunbird thing it's like
yeah like is everybody like big up on
Halo 5 like in a lot of its aesthetics
but no I yeah I don't care for Halo I
would like to go back and play that
multiplayer because I did like the
multiplayer quite a bit but yeah the 343
era of like art style I've never really
cared for which you know I think most
people feel that way and you know
they're kind of going back on it and
doing a new art style for infinite so I
messed up and try to take take out to
people and it got me
also I can't mail a canceled in remake
so like what's the point the point Oh No
hey get out of here someone's trying to
shoot me with their pistol yeah some
sighs it's the halo is the halo 4 engine
adjusted for 4 halo 2 gameplay need to
get in that game swap discord how are
you not in there yet a clue Brandon yeah
man she should be top Top Billing guy
get you in men dude y'all remember red
vs. blue do I still have my red vs. blue
DVDs on my shelf right next to me I
actually have them sent out here now so
I have mine as well yeah I have I have
both the DVDs and the blu-ray collection
I own of the like the 10th anniversary
blu-ray and I own the DVD ones I still
like keeping the DVD ones because the
DVD ones have those those DVD menus that
are like where they put a lot of like
dumb Easter eggs in them you know like
and like some really good jokes in those
DVD menus that you don't get on the
blu-ray menus because blu-ray man you
suck so I still keep those DVDs because
I like those menus and I think they're
super cool you read that like weird like
half second of existential crisis when
you're you're bearing down on someone
and you realize they haven't shot at you
yet because they have a shotgun yes it's
just I'll never forget the feeling
all right still no I feel about the
pistol inhale it too
I don't have Twitter's or anywhere else
you can contact us for the link to it
it's a good question damn we need to we
figured out cat week email it how you
didn't get my my stuff and order here I
haven't gotten a kill in a while Brennan
diva to have an email have you tried
emailing the after dark podcast for it
oh yeah that definitely works yeah yeah
another option is is you can email after
dark at GameSpot calm and ask for it
there and we can hook you up
chatter Magisters I still have my red
vs. blue high quality download episodes
from one else's sponsor and OG
roosterteeth days dude I did that as
well yeah yeah I like yeah it was like a
spy was a sponsor which they eventually
I think now it's been changed to like
roosterteeth first is what it's called
yeah and yeah I was like a sponsor and I
had I was in the forums
I remember download in episodes of like
season 5 so the next logical question is
you're talking about all this red vs.
blue stuff is what is your favorite like
joke from it oh god I'd have to remember
there's so many oh my god I got blind
off the top of my head I know exactly I
used to be able to quote red vs. blue
off the back of my head it's been so
long I okay though I know if it's my
favorite but the one that comes to mind
is when they that's a good one
is when they get this sword and they
find out that the the sword is is uh
they're explaining yeah I think it's
like Church is explaining to caboose
that it was like the sword could be used
to unlock something it was like also a
key and then caboose goes or like he's
like oh yeah I guess a sword turned out
to also be a key in capitis ghost or
maybe it was a key all the time and when
you stick it in people it unlocks their
death and the church just goes man I
would just love to hang out in your
world for like five minutes man it's
true this is the other like break off
necklace how many favorite like red vs.
blue jokes are tied to caboose Oh a lot
of them who is their favorite care who's
your favorite character I think I always
like Sarge of it just cuz he's he just
loud in dumb and so sure Sarge is great
I was
of Griff Griff is also good Griffin
Church for my two favorites yeah man is
a very good time yeah but I think he'll
says plus one for charge there it is
yeah I think my favorite joke that I can
I can like it it just stuck with me
because of how dumb and stupid it was in
like season two
sergeant caboose are like trying to get
into like like a base to do some sort of
like surveillance or something yes
I mean Sarge boosts caboose up and he's
like what do you see in there and he's
like there are some floors and some
ceiling wait one ceiling and that's just
it's just stuck with me so much and I
don't know why I love it it's less a
specific line but there's there's this
whole bit in I think it's season four or
five and maybe four where where where
Simmons is feeling like unappreciated so
he'd like paints his armor blue and
joins the blue team oh and and there's
this part where like like Church is like
oh yeah hey what happened to recruit and
he's like hanging out with him and
there's this part where he's talking
about the Reds he's like aya those are
the Reds and he's like explaining them
he's like oh that's Sarge you know he's
their leader he's kind of an idiot but
he can also be kind of crafting Grif I
think he's the smartest one there even
though he's really lazy and he's like
there's this other guy there too
I don't know everyone hated him no one
really liked him and he's like oh really
and he's like yeah they would always
like talk about him behind his back and
say how he wasn't cool and [ __ ] and then
like Simmons is like oh I have to go to
the bathroom and he like runs away and
then Sheila they're talking tank goes
you know that Simmons right and Church
is like oh yeah yeah I know
just like reveals that he's known it the
whole time
god that that show is such a good
example of just like you give these
characters very distinct personalities
and you just let them play off of each
other and like that that's really all
you need know now there's those original
those original seasons man my first car
was named Sheila heck yeah
that's what I'm talking about that's
that's the kind of energy we need man I
I'm gonna say it again I really
appreciate the fact that we have an
anniversary edition in this game well I
still I so I've still majorly preferred
the original we can swap over to
displaying the original I figured we
would do both
I'm I'm good playing playing whatever
it's just just just me making
observations be careful what I'm doing
there's just something about it my my
old man eyes can only tell apart stuff
in the whole dressed fair
I think that's one thing I didn't I
think like about the halo 4 and 5
Spartan armor is it was a little too
busy it was busy and they look like
small smaller than yeah I like how
chunky and I it's not just this like
because cuz to me it's not about like oh
you know it feels like a case of like
over-designed where it's like Oh more
design equals better and higher
resolution versus like the simplicity of
the silhouettes of that chunky original
armor it's just work so much better
oh that's a good guy I thought it was a
bad guy for a second hello where'd they
go yeah I'd be curious to see if how
halos design feels because I mean
infinite like is going back to that kind
of chunky or less busy look and that
sort of been the direction a lot of
shooters have been going in is like you
know free-to-play games and like games
like overwatch and and valor in are like
more simple but they're like it's easier
to read right like you're not distracted
by the busy work and I feel like Halo
kind of got a little halo needs to get
back to the to its roots you know a lot
of swords free you know I'm back at my
dumb garbage again
I can't keep me away from it I can then
whoa sniper who where I almost got shot
where are you I'm just warning the
bottom part of the map
thought you can sneak up on me you're
wrong nope oh that was a good grenade
well done line came out I botched it
mmm Kneedler you I forgot how bad the
Kneedler isn't hey well the needler I
don't think was very good until three
you can do wield it in this one which is
yeah but you like have to like it's
useless on its own
and I think the it's it's absolute
garbage in one like 300 no I'm gonna bad
place gameplay aside the pistol doesn't
seem to fit in the Halo universe is
design yeah it's I I'm not into it just
weird cuz like yet you went from like
the pistol in Halo one which is like
super iconic
and they tried to redesign it down to be
just like a regular looking pistol right
well that was weird why did it do that
hold on your camera got all messed up
you know so it wouldn't be the first
time it will be the last time this cord
what are you doing stop it man it's
doing things and I don't like it
hold on I'm holdin there we go okay
we're good now oh no I gotta pop that
back what happen to me
I don't know I fixed it
but discord just decided to like move
itself around I was like okay alright
that's good
one of those things eh hey Richie how's
it going I'm Richie in the chat what up
Richie oh I got it which are you a
little boy are you I know I know your
take on Cod were you were you a halo guy
I'm like Rene's into there
Oh sword let's get this do a pistol I'll
try again
come back here uh-huh Oh kind of friends
Red Eagle stick him out together
hmm next kill footage that us with them
no it's definitely that's us Wow
I play like I'm playing like garbage but
oh man
Ritchie says hallo guy up until 3 heck
yeah man
kill through is a good time yeah I
mentioned it earlier but I'm very
excited for it to eventually become a
thing uh anyone else like to join the
game anyone else in the chat one join
I'm pretty I'm pretty pleased with their
performance so far today
roasty yeah you're doing great man
yeah thank you let's give a minute see
if anyone's that she's been joining us
saw somebody joined the chat here but I
don't know oh I just got a shout-out to
my beard enough in a slack channel what
okay yeah yeah I I haven't done anything
to my facial hair at all since we've all
been locked down so this is just letting
it go and not caring it's a heck of a
thing oh I see hahaha [ __ ] I love it
I'll have to download it I would okay
well we'll keep on for now but if anyone
wants to join let me know and uh we'll
make sure to get you in a plus beanie
thank you I have a pile of beanies over
over oh that is a WAP between I've also
got like oh here I'm just gonna bunch of
stuff on my desk like like headbands and
stuff like I miss all my hats I
literally have a giant drawer at my desk
in the office that's just full of hats
oh no you got to get those hats back
yeah I didn't realize how long we'd be
away but I missed some of those hats
yeah
I've slightly related but I have a bunch
of like things that I ordered like a
very long time ago that are like finally
being shipped so I've been getting a
bunch of notifications recently in my
email being like hey this is a in the
mail room at the office and I'm like no
I have like five packages that I'm I've
got a waiting on I've got that bit
izabel dad hat coming in soon hmm
hopefully I got this you wanted it I I
got my Isabel merch my my animal
crossing merch dang but I think that
when I had shipped here so I think I'm
I'm still okay we should wear our Isabel
dad hats when we can have it you think
yeah okay geez I'm sorry it's all this
this beanie I don't know where it came
from but we're like cleaning out a bunch
of stuff and like Mike McCarty
accidentally kicked over a box and then
the half he's like you every knees all
the time take this that's how it keeps
me and the game swap being you that I
wear mm-hmm I stopped my playstation one
I think it's on my shelf I haven't used
it a bit because it's it's it's a bit of
a thicker beanie so it it's been kind of
warm and I've been trying to find like
smaller thinner ones first was always of
us I really do like the first one you
can't go to wrong with the first set of
Halo games yo ah turf
I love turf yeah hey I remember getting
up early to download the map so I could
run around in it the day it came out so
I could talk to my friends about it at
school
mm-hmm and I definitely charged so my
parents credit card when I shouldn't
have so I got to come back home from
feeling really cool talking about halo
Matthews heck yeah also a week to my
parents being like what the hell is this
seven
Shh they put a warthog in this map
there's no reason for them now it's
great I love it I can do it also have
these cool riches you can knock down
super jumping you're the Scarab
oh I never know how to do that I've
heard about that hell I got speak at her
roosterteeth red vs. blue that's an open
there's a there's a reference to that
and right there that's cool hey I don't
remember that being in the ER that must
be added I don't remember that in the
original map I feel like I would have
noticed that
lost the lead Meili opened these doors
to oh hello
they're always cool like things you
could just interact with on maps and it
was really neat
oh behind us got him Oh beeping of the
useless warthog oh [ __ ] do we gotta get
into that thing yeah we do
no no yeah yeah yeah all right I'm ready
go go go go go
everyone get in yeehaw okay we're doing
it now this is it there's someone inside
that building surprise this is their
idea that was worth it we gotta try that
again it definitely was worth its net
that's the type of stuff about halo that
you don't get in a lot of other shooting
now you really doubt like he's just a
quick little side thing where you just
get in a warthog in a map that's not
designed for it and just kind of go see
they've gotta fight all those people and
get my revenge on them
all right I know you're over here now my
body
so they're back in the Warthog Oh No the
map pack discs yeah when you had to like
you got the option to go and actually by
the the disks for it oh I got a I got a
betrayal I guess oh look that's looking
shop thing is so much hope they fix that
soon know what thing up the like
explosions like killing teammates oh
yeah yeah yeah they're not there cuz
that's super stupid I Foley I could
harness up for the power of good to kill
right allies or my enemies than I am ah
yes okay that's good much good mother
mr. Knapp is a dual wielding man this is
definitely doing map I've resigned to
not do anything else yeah
I had to have us friend come in
I'll take it
oh they all respawn on the street see
that I guarantee that betrayal wasn't on
purpose
probably not whoa kids with butter
knives would try to stop their xbox just
to play certain maps that's that's a new
one for me
yeah I've never heard of that I remember
having to use a butter knife because my
360 ease disc drive used to get stuck
yeah that sounds like a like an urban
myth type of status that's some that's
some golden warthog stuff you're on
right there no I remember the golden
warthog the the only like real good
memory I have of us action like my group
of friends actually tricking some poor
kid into like doing no in just for 30
minutes made them do like the dumbest
stuff and I hope that kids all right
somewhere I feel bad
those also a part of me that like
wonders like does that person that we
did that to like they're like a like a
25 year old man somewhere now and
they're like telling the story about the
time a bunch of high school kids like
told them that could find a golden
warthog if they like saying twinkle
twinkle little star back yeah right
either they're telling it to their
co-workers at the bar and having a good
time or they're telling it to their
therapist afterwards yeah it's it's a
heck of a thing ah assassinated oh
they're back in the in the truck again
no gotta play lockout oh heck yeah we
played the the anniversary version of a
lock yeah
there's no Matt voting they took that
out because everyone would just vote for
a hail of three maps which I did get a
little tired of it's the second time
I've been assassinated I can't believe
it Oh game over okay yes these matches
are going super quick do we want to try
and do like a something that isn't just
straight-up deathmatch jump down for
whatever
big team is like my main thing but you
want you want to try a halo halo too big
team I'm down I'm down for all take me
to coagulation do you want that a VA
right all the time every day
all right I've done a v8 everything
let's go let's see what happens that was
an image that image right there
is it that's exactly what I want that's
halo that Sun's up halo one singular
JPEG right there everyone get on the
tank grab the flag yeah let's go good
well 45 on halo to lots of people today
sure it's every week a different game
Hermes as every different game yes
sometimes it depends on what kind of is
like we try to make it as topical as you
can like if a new game came out right or
we're already throwing around the idea
of doing like you go fighting games when
Evo rolls around maybe we like mixing it
up but we also have our old standbys
that we go back to yeah like if there's
a day or a week where nothing has
happened
mmm just pumping because it's exactly oh
I'll check out the butter knife thing I
I feel like it's the thing that people
definitely did but I didn't never run
into it
yeah because I've personally never heard
of that I believe it it sounds like
something that you'd tell people because
you know it'll like mess up the discs
yeah like [ __ ] their game up like oh
yeah definitely well that thing is
spinning just jam a knife in there it'll
help you find that it'll stop the laser
on the right part of the disc well I've
never seen the anniversary version of
this map yeah we got Mongoose mongeese
alrighty whoo let's do it
I actually didn't even recognize the map
until I got immediately the physics I
love it oh no
yeah look fine no we flipped over
immediately yeah god this is a gorgeous
looking map holy crap it looks so
different though oh hey Ben can I happen
with you happy ow ow ow ow ow okay hi
dude I'm getting up
alright there we go we're definitely
gonna die but like we're gonna die in
styles yeah that's kind of the important
bit
yeah I died that's why your sorry shield
popping them like Oh me get around the
corner quick enough mongooses are really
good for capture-the-flag it's true
there is the gun goose in this one I
think they added that yeah that's what
that one was but it can only shoot like
in a 30 degree arc in front of it right
the evil eye awfully cool school girls
yeah I'm very excited that they
readjusted it and it's interesting to
see how the effort put into having a
solid online for a fighting game it's
paying off now in a big way on a huge
stage yeah I'm glad that died man I love
skull girls big shame I've been trying
to get back into and play more oh I'm
not very good at it now so much now you
know who is Persia Persia's that's one
of her favorite games
she loves that game ooh I forgot about
the suppressed SMG that we put into this
- this thing looks flippin gnarly oh
yeah it looks rad I don't actually know
what statistically it really does all
that much better but it's just aesthetic
difference but it looks sick yeah I was
loved hounds good I always loved that in
ODST
I was not that looks so cool so nice to
see how happy people are about halo as
of late yeah it's it's always good to be
excited about things that you like
looks cool equals better I agree eagle
it's true that's why it's it's fashion
Souls world of fashion crafts flip in
it's all about looking good that's how
it works it's true
what I'm not writing and zip you better
bet I'm putting a together really good
transmog to make my character look cool
oh yeah so if you like Alex say yeah
right
I felt that betrayal stuff doesn't work
in the anniversary which is a relief
oh they're all here no everyone's here
halos concept artists is amazing yes it
is to 20% also skyboxes in Halo games oh
yeah can't be beaten uh top gasps here
but Bungie in particular yes it's like
that I would also say that that
translates to destiny that game it's got
some gorgeous sky boxes it's very true
chef's the butter knife thing is real oh
man it said that weird like it's it's
interesting because you got like that we
had kind of urban urban legend myth
thing going on that you'd have in like
playgrounds but somehow made his way
online I got your back oh all right say
it's uh it's also worth mentioning now
just where we've already been going for
like an hour and 15 oh yeah and I have
mentioned it once but if you do like
what you see and you haven't already
subscribed to the channel you should
it's that way you won't miss any of the
live streams we do you want miss any of
the cool videos we do it's the best way
to kind of keep up on what's going on
immediately mm-hmm and we hope that you
do cuz I'd like to see all of you back
here and we can all hang out and maybe
halo isn't your thing maybe a game that
we play somewhere down the line is and
you'll be there for that exactly one day
we'll slip up and we'll be like guys
let's play Street Fighter 5 and it turns
out you're actually the best in the
Midwest and you just come in and
completely stop us in to the grounds and
that's what I'm looking forward to and
as we previously mentioned if you want
to keep up with what we're playing at a
time the best way to do that is to join
the GameSpot discord server which you
can at near been on Twitter and we'll
hook you up with an invite for that you
can also email after dark podcast at
GameSpot calm it's a another good Avenue
to get an invite to the discord but we
got just big team Slayer who's hoping
for a more objective match well uh well
I'll turn Slayer off
when we go back in play light in the day
and I'll join for halo any day
yeah what will fluctuate between what
day works best it made the most sense
today to do 11 but we'll see what what
makes the most sense here yeah there's a
lot of a lot of shift in a movement
happen and now we're being being active
about it yeah but if - if like - is like
a better time for people to get more
people in I'm happy to adjust that when
when necessary thing this guy tried to
run me over on a warthog and almost
drove off the map alright Ben we need
get a vehicle together we do oh there is
a warthog on the beach I know that I am
heading over to it oh hey it's the same
one oh shoot get out of here I'll cover
you so go let's circle back on me never
mind I got it good okay yeah we're all
together yeah let's do it let's ride
whoo he's a lot tired about so the
Warhawk sounds sick but not in the good
way
I'm sorry I had to make that distinction
boy I mean I I would have assumed it was
the other one that's fair oh god what
happened to the the chat or the game
hold on the what sorry
he's just flipping out the game screen
like moved on stream hold on I know well
let me lock that in you flew off the
handle with the word hog I wonder how
that happened hopefully that wasn't up
there too long all right let's try to
find another where hard
that one like blow up properly okay yeah
I think it did know that shot come from
how did he know I was there yeah people
merely sniping in this map with battle
rifles battle rifles are so good though
they are
oh damn that was a good shot
over here trying to make it back into
like a good place for cover can't do it
not good enough
where you at been I'm up on the the main
structure working my way up with the
with awesome some good old chaps no my
body no bow back for the two-three style
vehicle health
so for each vehicles have their own
health and died too easily yeah I agree
I'm into it my person is almost done
flipping nailed all those shots
oh you're moving in on the same guy I am
whoo-hoo both of those boys very nice I
had your back the whole time I
appreciate it no do you have the
Covenant sniper go damn Mike oh that guy
from that far away
that seems busted your buses are just
right depends on if I'm on the receiving
end or not that's fair
yeah this is pretty busted but feels
real good over here go up on that yeah
when you when you in the the high point
it feels good
damn that was really close yeah whoa
that gun goose was this was roaming all
right let's get another one going man
yeah yeah yeah let's hold up again it's
a real staff sergeant scenario for me
right now all right we're gonna do
something that isn't Slayer an objective
game I love it
yeah the UH do do we want to call what
we were thinking about doing doing next
week just in case uh yeah well we're
yeah what were we thinking about again
oh right I remember now yeah do you want
to do you want to pitch it to people you
saw you okay I think we're gonna try and
do Grand Theft Auto five because a lot
of people got that for free thanks to
the epic store is that still what is the
epic store still down because of that
and it was not like a thank you I hope
it's equal how long is that a for free
for was it just yesterday or is it uh so
it's a week long thing because they're
doing like new new free games every week
right for their big feel that they're
doing right but you got to keep it you
get it in you have it right you have it
it's there
yes install it you get to go it's also
like 80 gigs so I guess it's a good
thing to tell people how to time yeah
they want to load so if you want to play
with us you still have a week to go get
that game for free on the epic story and
then we're gonna just do so we're just
gonna mess around in Grand Theft Auto
for fun games just can't a weird old
time driving around doing things okay
it's KITT bring that cat in cattle just
woke up from like a nap behind me
probably come over oh dang we're getting
all these anniversaries Maps today we're
on this redone version of coagulation
and it's a looks intense nope alright
what are we doing big team king of hell
oh right the Hornet dude let me get in
let me get one it's weird I want to get
on the side seat alright you all you all
go there I'll take that the Mongoose man
sounds good
this is a lot
I'm gonna drop off here oh this is a bad
place
I'm got the hill fort when I airlifted
in and just got like a triple kill oh
that was excellent
nope hop on then fear hop on Ben hold on
you might need to go without me just cuz
I am a plan okay
I'm gonna take out their horn it with
the rocket launcher no feel like
accidentally
okay I'm gonna god this gun goose is a
mess you could only shoot straight yeah
it's it's a very tight pattern - oh my
body
sniper found me oh no someone got spammy
with it don't need to do that there's no
reason okay
he'll changing he'll is moved you can't
not like repeat what the announcer says
in this game it's impossible so good
whoa okay we are crushing it right now
hey ya know they're up on the hill and
are above a proper base
Oh from behind
no vehicles over here we got to make the
whole run now we're to move to okay
King good news I picked up the sniper
rifle so I'm ready to botch it uh uh
excuse me Oh Oh actually know about that
there's an EMP on the base that you can
use to disable vehicles if they try to
escape with a flag oh that's new yeah I
guess be booths in the hill interesting
all right
oh I just got a head shot on a guy mono
out of Mongoose there mind I'm really
good with the sniper rifle I take
everything back that one players
convinced me whoa oh hello
so everyone's favorite halo I think I
like reaches story but I like halo two's
multiplayer the most but I really love
reaches reaches multiplayer to Hale
threes multiplayers really good yeah I
think three is like the overall package
is my favorite yeah a lot of people
don't like the equipment but I I'm kind
of down with ok I don't think they're
the best but I think they're there they
got their moments scooping dodging
Rockets over here dude this is uh I'm
glad that the last match of the day is
on flippin Blood Gulch yeah or what
coagulation whatever the version of the
universe is this one's called the
coagulation and I think reaches was
called hemorrhage yeah
yikes
we had a that capture point you - can I
get say hey we gotta steal the slope uh
who's shooting me
ah site how often does it rain they're
not actually that often in the end the
bay yeah I could stand for maybe a
little more RAM and we usually get we
did have that what's up this year where
it was like a good two weeks where it
was non-stop raining yeah that was nice
that's pretty rare oh come on damn okay
why are you spinning game
yikes this guy the gun something about
the gun goose flipping in the air while
it's still shooting is the funny [ __ ] to
me
got the hill oh there's a man in the in
the rocks way far away I can't
ing Minh that's cool Hank you also that
achievement popped up real big on my
screen oh you're something moved again
oh man Ben I'm sorry it's it's okay it's
both of our things moved D what is going
on I mean obviously I'm the one moving
it by accident but dude it's it's fine
there we go okay I have lost everything
over they won't move do you want to do
one more yeah let's do one more
hey I'm having a good time I'm in a good
time as well do you want to do classic
halo2 or do you want to I'm good alright
we'll just let we'll just let it go I'll
see you happens tank people call out
your language shall okay where you
popping off about that Mongoose we try
to we try to you know sometimes ah sick
we got stone town I've been there the
Galleria I miss it Oh
I'll roll with the same same group it
looks likes you so that's good
Slayer uh-oh it's Fiesta this is the
most chaotic thing ever it's my favorite
game we're doing big team oh never mind
this is the perfect way to end the
stream I'm so I'm so happy oh oh no oh
oh it's already chaos yeah I love it
thank you for cleaning that up yeah no
worries I got you you know a lot of
hiding over there oh I'll take it
well happy I uh I know scoped a guy if
we he killed me at the same time but I
will take that hell yeah sure so where's
the fight at what's happening oh this
guy - sword shoot Oh Darren over oh wow
I had two weapons last time I only spawn
into the needler this time
with the frame rate on this one is get a
little rough
you'll bend you want getting this or hug
do it yeah ah there's a guy with a sword
there don't pick that up in case I need
to jump off in sort of man 1
yeah yeah yeah oh that guy's got a sword
to know that dude flippin was like aa
warthog in the distance I hear it
picked me right off
oh I got a rocket and sword that seems
like a bad combo I got a shotgun and a
sword slick I mean I'm all about just
running and jumping I'm getting in close
well I got the Sentinel beam so you know
I mean business Oh know that about Danny
I was out of rocket energy that have
been so cool carbine whoa oh my god
just excuse me hello oh where is
everyone
I love when people try to sneak up on me
and then I just have the fuel rod Canada
panics shoot like four shots all at once
it's good [ __ ] man
it really is oh excuse me
I really want to do more with this SMG
that's suppressed yeah it just it looks
so good it does stuck there we go thank
you
I'll pick this up
how about dueling suppress smg's that's
the good stuff
nice melee thank you Oh sword
oh hello
No
cut the framerate it's all these all
these weapons it's a lot to keep track
of
oh my God why did I stick around
well what dude oh wow that guy blew my
thing what the [ __ ] man no good
fuel rod okay let's go
no man I love Zanzibar and such a good
map it really is it's it's the like it
stop to your asymmetrical design it's
got the lanes it's got the the style to
it it's real good
Oh what is even happening
oh geez
the finding a way to counter the snipers
as a tech of a thing oh god that was a
really fun match to end on I enjoyed
that quite a bit yeah yest as always
just a good big dumb good time
it really is whoo all right then yeah
yeah well ship packing that has been
another week of gamespot community
Friday's hallo to huge shout out to b-17
eagle for playing with us today you're
the MVP man it's true really appreciate
it thank you everyone in the chat who
has been hanging out with us
like we've said if you like what you see
and you want to see more make sure to
subscribe the game spot hit that Bell
all that stuff so that you can see it we
try and do community Fridays every
Friday obviously and if you want to know
what we're playing ahead of time you can
follow me and bet on Twitter which we
have our Twitter handles right here but
also you can join the GameSpot official
discord server we put all the
information in there ahead of time so
that people can come in and play with us
you can hit me and Ben up on Twitter or
you can email after dark podcast at
GameSpot calm if you want invite to that
next week we are playing Grand Theft
Auto 5 on the PC it's free for now with
epic so if you want to play with us go
ahead and get that bought and downloaded
so that you can play with us and we'll
do I'm sure we'll do some some
shenanigans from that oh it'll be really
stupid yeah till then see you guys next
time
goodbye
you